[Music]
christmas is sort of coming up this is
the time of the year where holidays are
starting to happen i'm very excited for
the holiday season and we have a
tradition christian and i every year
with our family we would go on christmas
eve to a friend's house a family friend
uh shout out to the sapolas
and i think nicholas might listen i hope
he does i um
hopefully even if they don't i feel like
they're gonna want to listen to this one
because well we'll get to that in a
second but uh they make this incredible
seven course fish dinner it's a
traditional italian dinner and um
christmas eve dinner yes yes that's the
tradition right yes i wonder why that's
a tradition we should know we should
have done the research we should know
after why seven
there's probably a you know what we're
gonna get shamed for not knowing this
christmas eve
if they're listening so hopefully
they're not listening well by then we
should probably do the research but
seven days in a week
maybe fish a day seven the doctor away
maybe seven of the disciples uh were uh
pescetarians uh oh uh oh now um
we're veering into some maybe
potentially offensive territory but he
suffice to say
and that's suffice to say i use that
incorrectly i was into it i like that
you used that i know it was a good
bridge it was a good bridge phrase but
you couldn't follow through no no
because i realized it doesn't really
make sense suffice to say i was gonna
say suffice to say we have fun every
year and it's it's a delicious meal i
think that's good you think yeah
especially if they're listening and you
know who's definitely listening our
parents yes because they love our not us
our guests today i hope hopefully they
love us as well life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your not 100 italian host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my equally
partially italian brother you're both
every person italian
yes we're both we're partially italian
our grandmother friend of the show and
our um our favorite our grandma jody uh
she was
fully italian yes uh fratelli was her
last name this is where
finale oh boy fratelli i'm thinking of
goonies i'm thinking of the the band and
there's a fratelli's restaurant in otis
oh yes that's right is that still open
yeah uh anyway she was she was fully uh
italian that's where we get
most of what makes us italian yes but
our father who is not um
genetically
all that italian he's gonna love to hear
that he's not gonna like to hear this
but
he's not gonna like it because he loves
italy and he loves all things he loves
italian culture and um he knows so much
about the history and he lived there for
a long time yes when he was in the
seminar he's a real italian file he sure
is is that the right term
probably not no we're gonna get shamed
for this he's also very bright
um and the the family friend of ours uh
is also is fully italian they're his
last name uh means onion in fact in
italian and um he's layered like an
onion he is
uh we have so much fun as we said going
over there but um every year as a funny
thing happens when ever since like 1990
the mid-90s we've been going there for
since
probably the mid 80s but around the mid
90s he started asking a specific
question which was
uh he was really taken by this movie and
he would say to me um because he knew
that i was into acting and our older
brother was into acting and so he would
always say he tried he was nice you'd
try to connect to us uh about movies and
he'd say
oh my have you seen
big night there's a movie called big
night that had just come out and
i hadn't and every year thereafter he
would he would bring it up again it
would always come up it would come up
every year for at least a decade yeah
and i throughout that whole decade i've
since seen it but i've i hadn't seen it
for so long and i always felt a little
deficient and you might be thinking well
why didn't you just watch it that's what
i was just thinking yeah they'd be we
had vcrs we had a pcr um for the younger
listeners that was the way that you
watched movies right back in the day
that you'd put in it was all very
old-fashioned which is crazy but um
it it's it didn't appeal to me at the
time i don't know why i i
i wasn't that into cooking at the time
and um
anyway now i am and and it stars two of
my favorite actors i've gotten to work
with one of those actors uh tony
shalhoub
in my first movie uh
and now uh we have another actor from
that movie the director of that movie
and the writer and the writer
the great i mean really like one of our
great actors and um
and now uh one of our one of my favorite
guests you're about to hear why
uh stanley tucci touch the tooch tucci
gang turner and touch oh that was good
oh that was good by the way
yeah anyway i'll get to it you're gonna
say there's a new turner and hooch out
now no is there there is a tv series tom
hanks in this one no josh peck plays the
uh oh tom hanks roll
i i guess i can see that yeah he plays
the tom hanks not the not the hooch he
plays turner um no i'm just trying to
think of other stanley two ones okay
sorry
um i saw your eyes drift away
all right i won't touch oh god oh geez
okay um
susan tucci stanley tucci is like you
were saying one of our great actors and
writers and directors and uh he's been
in uh some great
classic movies he was also in the devil
where's prada julian julia oh the cat
the katniss um oh all the hunger games
games yeah uh
yes and he was in tale of despero a
movie that i was fired from he's been in
so much uh and he now has
a book out that um it's it's one of my
favorite books that i've read it's one
of the only books i've read in a while
to be fair uh but it's it's a memoir
that combines his love of food and his
love of cooking uh with with his
tales of growing up and and coming up in
the business as an actor and it's really
funny and heartbreaking and some
incredible recipes can i find out the
name oh sorry it's called
tooch i mean it tastes hot yeah
taste yeah taste taste by touch taste by
touch um he is
and just such a game like playful spirit
i i was surprised because sometimes
those actors who are very respected and
kind of like clap he's a classy actor
yeah maybe we find out how it went
afterwards that's true because that's
the that's the format that's what we do
every year yeah every week for well over
100 episodes yes
so um okay good you wanted to stick to
that formula yeah why not okay
if it ain't broke if it ain't that broke
um and so here we go the formula with
the man himself with the tooch
stanley tucci
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello hello
[Music]
this is about life i think and uh the
joys
of life um i'm holding up for those of
you just listening to this as a podcast
which is what it is um i'm holding up
stanley's book taste my life through
food i can't wait to talk to you about
it um your book is so much of it about
is about food it's you're getting into
your life through your joy of food and
cooking and um
growing up was we're there i'm i'm i
know they're great restaurants there now
where i grew up they're you know that's
become very in vogue uh a lot of italian
cooking but what was it like what was
culinarily what was your upbringing like
there i grew up in westchester new york
katona
there was nothing outside of my house
i mean i i think
i wrote in
or nothing that i knew of um that you
know because it wasn't uh it wasn't um
affordable to go out to a to a
restaurant you know my dad was an art
teacher at the
at in horse greely high school oh no
and my mom worked in in the office i
mean it wasn't in teacher salaries as we
know
in a public school or not
uh substantial so go on my mom was a
teacher a school teacher my dad was a
university taught at fairfield u oh
really yes i i understand yeah no you
know it wasn't like hey let's go out to
the you know like
no
our special thing was luigi's there was
a restaurant there was a family italian
restaurant and uh my dad loved i mean
they love you you're a huge part of uh
huge in our home in the last oh my god
very celebrated um
italian cooking and um so they're
excited about this as am i uh but every
once in a while my mom was such a good
cook you know and yeah um you come from
a sicilian and a brutzy and so
who you're who your mother my mother's
mother was abhruzi from oh really oh
yeah amazing food yes amazing food and
so i grew up i'm very lucky to have um
had that uh in my house every year just
got used to it spoiled by it um but but
what do who cooked in your family what
was uh
my mom my mom cooked and and she learned
from her mom who
you know
and i was lucky enough to know her mom
for a long you know big part of my life
and um
you know that's where my love of cooking
comes from my my father's dad
also cooked uh as did his
uh family his his sisters cooked
and
you know the combination of those two
families
those recipes just informed
everything they told they taught me
everything i bet and how much of it as a
kid was an actual interest in the
cooking or was it just was it as simple
as wanting to be around mom and dad
wanting to be uh with them and witness
what they were doing it was both it was
both i mean the food thing is the food
was so good
that
you wanted you couldn't help but want to
find out
how it was made yes it's like you want
the magic trick you want to yeah you
want to know and of course
it's always very vague
with a home cook
because they say well then
when i had to pin my mother down
27 years ago to
to
figure out
this cookbook that we put together that
was originally called cucina a familia
which is now called the tucci cookbook
uh
it uh it was hard because those recipes
you know they're
they're taught and yet they're still
instinctual
there are rules but there are no rules
right and so much of it is that that's
that's the joy that i find in watching
somebody like that cook because it's
it's so artistic they look like mad
scientists you know a little bit there's
that element of like chaos and my
grandma passed recently and and uh i'm
sure
no no we were like as were you we were
lucky to be with her for a long time she
was 104 and um she was what yeah she was
104 and jesus up until the end still so
vibrant and present it didn't feel like
you know what i imagine most 104 year
old not to i don't want to alienate it
or 100 our centurion audience
no but she she was on this podcast in
fact we talked to an amazing recall
which is something else i want to talk
to you about i was struck by
your in your book that just the
the recall that you had how how how much
of that did you have to fill in did you
have to guess at and you mentioned how
difficult it is to to pass on these
recipes and to glean
how to cook this stuff did you have to
go to people in your life and and get uh
yeah i just started you know it was
interesting because i would
you know sometimes if you're writing
something about
yourself you're not sometimes actually
always you're slightly embarrassed and
you don't want to
sort of
oh and and then i did this and then i
wrote you know it's like you're like who
cares you know it's a little bit like
these sometimes too do you find that
like you get embarrassed you're like oh
god it's so boring yeah um i'm i'm the
most boring person in the world
but i guess maybe people think i'm not
but but i think one of the things you
want to do is
tell the story in a way that it was told
to you
and
in the best way that you know how
without being uh hyperbolic without
being
melodramatic just want to tell that
story like this was my grandmother this
was my mother this is me
and those things are the things that
connect you and put it out there to
people stanley what do you think it is
about food i mean and your relation to
food that that seemed like a natural way
in to because i've never read a book
like i've never it's such an interesting
way to get into a life you know to do it
through this very specific lens um
something that you're very clearly
passionate about but what is it about
food and the idea of cooking that you
thought would lend itself to getting
into your life
well i think it's obviously it's one of
the first connections we have with our
mothers
right
uh breastfeeding which of course in the
1960s when i was born
they didn't do that
that was frowned upon in america
so there was no breastfeeding there was
formula and formula as it turns out if
you're
lactose intolerant or if you have uh
what are they called you know where
babies can't eat silly um
yeah something like right so if you have
that but you're still told breastfeeding
isn't good right because that was my old
rule yeah right yeah um you
were given this formula that was just
terrible for you
so if your world starts that way uh-huh
but then your mother is feeding you in
this incredibly healthy way it creates
this very interesting dynamic
which you
eventually end up understanding and
dealing with
but i think the real thing is the
mothers or the families great cooking
and the focus on that and the love of
that and then where does that take you
that takes you to
a place of conviviality that takes you
to a place of tradition that takes you
to a place of connection
that's what food is for me and then it
takes you to a place of growth
as you become older
yeah i've recently really fallen in love
with cooking myself and i love doing it
i found this this is a new
joy that i've found is doing it for
people that i love uh there's something
about putting in
lending some kind of artistic
talents or abilities to this thing for
somebody i mean to do it it's the doing
it for somebody that i yeah what have
you what have you
let me interview you for a moment yeah
yeah um so what is it that you like to
cook why did you start cooking and what
was the last thing you cooked um
pasta there's a hedy mckinnon uh recipe
that i i was that i love um that's the
last thing i cook
is um she does uh she's in asia she does
a lot of asian influence uh
recipe i think her last book is to to
asia with love um oh wow but she she was
she does stuff there are a lot of
recipes of hers on the new york times um
oh wow okay cook cookbook um recipe site
whatever instagram so i found one for
orchier it's an orchidi uh
mushroom leek pasta that is the last
thing i cooked for my grandma
oh i sent you the recipe stanley yeah
um yeah and it was a big hit with her as
a past the grammar test and um so i made
it for my my own mom recently as a for
her birthday as a way to but that's
that's what it is as a way to kind of
remember her and it's the way my grandma
expressed her love and yeah you know
this same seems to be true of your
family um you you've been talking about
uh getting those recipes 20 years ago
when you were compiling that cookbook
yeah
how i interrupted you how did you end up
filling in those gaps in terms of the
the specifics of the recipes
well you just have to keep trying it
that's the thing you you have to keep
trying the recipe over and over again
you go
what that doesn't work
what's that and then you call your
mother
and you say mom
i'm making blah blah blah yeah uh in the
book it says this and she'll say
says that and then then
and then i'll say yeah
and she and she'll say oh no no that's
not right i said but mom it's it's in
the book we tested this recipe ad
nauseum
he says no no that's not right that's
not right i wouldn't do that i would do
this and you'd think oh god
that was years of work
but i admire but i really admire it
because
you know
i think i said this in the book that
they always maintain a secret there's
always a secret
too and italians are very secretive i
think particularly southern italians and
this in this is
due this behavior
is due to
the uh
number of uh
how shall i put it
and then the number
lightly stanley yeah
the number of invasions over the
centuries
so italians in particular the southern
times are incredibly protective
it's interesting which is one of the
reasons gate elise who's a guy tunnel to
lazy who's a great writer
about the italian experience uh italian
immigrant experience he and
he he said that basically italians
are incredibly secretive and play things
sort of
uh keep things close to the best because
they have been invaded so many times
that they trust no one
unless they are italian and that's also
why
they they speak with their hands
oh no kidding because it's a way of
expressing
whatever you need to express but you can
do it without sound oh wow that's
it makes perfect sense it does it does
and that that would extend to recipes
obviously yes it would extend the recipe
so you don't trust anybody so but you
also but you also believe that you're
arresting your recipe for
you know whatever ragu
or zucchini whatever is the best and
you're going to keep it but you're in
the family
and because the guy next door if you say
oh i had that at the guy next door
people are going no oh that's so funny
so so where's were your parents reticent
to
you know let you put this out no but
it's unconscious yeah yeah it's not con
they don't know that they're doing not
my father my father's much more
open and my mother would be very
sort of then you say and even johnny who
wrote the first cookbook with my parents
parents who is
a professional chef
like a trained french trained chef
he trained anthony bourdain i mean the
guy is like and and he even he will go
oh is that what i said
uh he he'll just say yeah well it
depends
so this idea of mistrust yeah ambiguity
i find really really really interesting
and it's what
it makes me go back to it all the time
because
it's not math yeah yeah
right well that's what i love about i
also love i was terrible at math and i
loved the um i hated yeah i think the
boundaries of it i suppose are the
strictures that are placed on
creativity um yes and i do love that
like even with this hedy mckinnon recipe
it was like you know i i i tried a few
the third or fourth time i made it i
started experimenting and trying uh well
it might be nice with some shallots
instead of garlic you know whatever it
is it was even small i love that about
it um yeah yeah it becomes you you
personalize it yeah yeah it becomes um
well it becomes
subjective yeah yeah yeah
do you are you do you love gardening are
you very connected to um plants as well
i do i do we don't have a big garden
here and and my
when i was in america i had uh
more land i mean the house that i sold
was a very old farmhouse uh and i had
six acres of land which was sort of all
you know different sort of
weedy and
some of it was fields that's the one in
salem
yeah in south sudan and it was so pretty
and i had a vegetable garden i had a
vegetable garden and basically
every house i i had and i and i really
loved it and
but this year you know we just did here
felicity did we did uh
some tomatoes which are not easy to grow
in a very sort of moist climate
uh and um we did some lettuce and some
peas and it was beans it was really nice
it's nice yeah there's something about
it i feel so much more connected to even
food that i hadn't but you have a garden
do you have a oh you can sure it's very
funny
pathetic uh it's time this year yeah oh
but that's so pretty yeah look at that
yeah wait where where are you and how
come i'm not there stanley come uh come
visit yeah it's so beautiful it's it's
in new york great barrington it's in the
berkshires it's like in uh oh i know
where you are
gorgeous it's beautiful uh i i don't
want to leave but um but yeah there's
something about especially tomatoes you
know i've fallen in love with tomatoes
after having grown them i was never
crazy about them which sounds crazy but
um i don't know the freshness of it and
the idea that you did it you're you know
that you
start to finish um yeah tomatoes are the
most amazing
i mean to see them
well in the book i don't know what if
you have a hard cop what do you have the
paperback yeah the paperback so in the
in the hard copy of the book i there's a
sketch that i did a little like
watercolor thing
of tomatoes at the beginning and the end
of the on the
excuse me
on the pages at the beginning
and it's
because i love them yeah i mean i love
them but also i just love to
look at them and i love the way they
grow i love to see them come to life and
i'd love to see them die
yes it's funny i'm looking at there's
some of them they're about to um change
color and they're just
yeah and i remember one time
this is kind of a gross story because
i hope
okay so
when i was in westchester we had to redo
the septic thing oh i like it already
all right so this guy
that i went to high school with
this is one of the things he did uh so
he had to dig it we had to
take out the old septic tank dig a whole
new thing then we had to put in new
leech fields and all that wow
all right so this is quite an expensive
yeah operation
so
they dig out the septic tank take out
the septic tank put in a temporary
septic tank i think
but there's this pile of dirt that sits
no they put in a new septic tank and
it's all covered up but there's this
pile of dirt
that's big like not like a little pot
like a big pile you could climb up that
had been over the previous septic tank
yes so that was part of
around it yeah
so it's sitting there and i say to the
guy you know when are you gonna move
this he's like oh we're so busy and you
know i'm like okay this is big [ __ ] it's
like dirt it's like [ __ ] dirt it's like
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
so
it's the technical term for it yeah
yeah so i say
okay he's like yeah yeah
so
spring comes summer comes
and i look
you know the kids are climbing up and
you're like get off the [ __ ]
and
and then i look and i see this
plant
and i'm like
it's a tomato plant
and then i go around to the other side
of the pile and there's another one huh
and then
they start growing and they grow
and there are tomatoes
growing
two different kinds of tomatoes no
kidding one is a roma tomato and one is
like a pomodorino like a little
dimension
they grew
from the seeds
in the [ __ ] no kidding like a bird like
the white birds do yes so
we in essence i mean that's how amazing
this plant is yes
and we ate the tomatoes
and they were really good
i bet i bet i bet they were extra
juicy and fur i mean like
you're extra human yes yes yeah did you
know based on the taste of the tomato
exactly who who's where it came from no
i didn't but i'm gonna experiment i'll
find out i'll let you know yeah
[Music]
christian was just leaving the house and
i said hey where'd you get those
sweatpants because i was intrigued
because they were cool looking but they
also looked like they were comfortable
they fit really nicely on you it's vyori
is what it is sure is i asked you and
you said it's fiore unless you were
lying no i'm still wearing them look
yeah oh yeah they're great um
well it's built to move and sweat and
that's what they say is that accurate i
wasn't sweating at the moment you were
moving i was moving they're uh built to
move and sweat and standing you were
standing in them briefly and sit you can
kind of do anything with them and their
mission is to create quality products
without extra waste and they offset 100
of their carbon footprint i should have
led with that that's instead of how good
you looked i was flattered you looked
environmentally conscientious i felt
environmentally conscientious there was
women's performance joggers you weren't
wearing that but you could have i could
have been yeah there's no rules about
that the men's core short yes nice the
men's ponto short
uh you weren't it's not short weather
anymore yeah what are your favorite
items uh well i mean the ones i'm
wearing right now okay stop bragging
about it we get it these gray
performance joggers are i also have
green performance joggers and i like to
change up my color palette now you can
get 20 off your first purchase at
com slash viori.com that's v u o r i
v ori v u o r i dot com slash long for
20 off
[Music]
as your wonder at the world and in the
natural world has that changed after
experiences that you've had with such
tragic experiences but experiences that
i imagine
yeah it put life in real perspective
yeah without question i mean when my
you know my
wife kate died yeah that certainly turns
your life
completely upside down yeah um
and she died in that house that i was
just talking about
so
it was sad to leave that house not bad
just letting go of the memories of i
mean the environment in which you knew
her yeah yeah because you're you know
and she was a very outdoorsy person
yeah um
you know i'm an outdoors but but she was
even much more we had you know she had
horses six acres that's intense yeah i
mean it was it was a weird six acres but
yeah it was it wasn't all usable
no no no i can't say it was all arable
yes
but um uh
but she was uh you know she loved all
that so it was very difficult to to
leave that um
but also
just
ha you know that i think that that
connection
to the to the land to growing
things yourself as as you know
is incredibly important yeah um and we
obviously have lost that along the way
it's it's coming back
um in in in the form of you know
small artisanal
farms yeah you know
um but i think particularly in england
which i think is a really good thing
um farm to table places yeah yeah i
think that's really really important the
problem is we we have to make that
accessible to everybody
um and not just some sort of rarified
oh it's for the wealthy people that's a
dwell on kate but i'm wondering if there
are
if there's a particular recipe that she
had or a food that she was
she cooked that that was uniquely hers
that you've able to pass on yeah i mean
we put it and the great thing is when i
when i married philistine we we did
felicity and did a cookbook together
about seven years ago i guess she's
great by the way i i spent a night with
her and emily in uh at the chateau years
ago and she was oh you did they're the
most fun i mean emily and we've had
karaoke nights and stuff with john but
uh
she was awesome she was such a fun like
kind person um
she's an amazing person and i'm i'm
i feel incredibly lucky at my ripe old
age to have met somebody like that no i
mean you know i meant you know you're
not a spring chicken and and i
i i really am so so lucky she's amazing
she's so funny and and we were lucky
enough actually to have john and emily
here for like a year oh no they were
living here for a year because she was
shooting in
spain john's shooting all over the place
oh yeah and they were like
literally we could walk to their house
oh that's all the kids would be together
all the time and i i am
really missing them
back now and yeah yeah they're fun
people it was really fun oh my god we
had the best time i bet oh my god and
are you in that dynamic are you pretty
much cooking for everyone is that your
role yeah yeah yeah but then emily you
know em's a great cook uh-huh so um we
would go over to their house and she
would cook and
um and then they'd come over here and we
would cook it's really really nice
people listening that's great no they
can then you cook for the kids which is
just basically pasta and butter and
cheese
are you ever like let down when they're
when they don't get how good some of
your cooking is something that you're
really proud of totally and they're like
insulted
depressed i always wonder that about
having kids it's like i said i would
love to have kids but it seems like
sometimes i see my
my my brother with his kids and they're
they're just these demanding little they
can no i could see the way and i was
probably like this with my own mother
who who went out of her way to cook us
really great yes but you know for
one of the things that kills me the most
is for our school lunches my mom would
you know healthy
meals she wasn't
a psychopath about it but like
she you know she cooked well and and
she'd write little notes and i always
wanted to trade my stuff like for
twinkies and stuff that that was like
contraband in my family of course yeah
yeah well i wrote about i actually wrote
about it in the book my lunches yes
so this is 19.
so if you're going to elementary school
right i'm like so
six years old whatever
so 1966.
kids call you stay what
what they call you stan or stanley
uh i think they call me stan i think
which at the time and still
is like who names their child that well
i suggested i love laurel and hardy so
much that that's always a name that i've
loved because of that stan lee i can
just hear
oliver the same thing yeah stanley
welcome
i hope i hope when you have children
you'll name them stanley but you you
have to name them stanley laurel that's
true and make that island or along yes
all the kids will get the reference
right away yeah right the millennials
question without question
yeah so sorry
you know so we would i would bring these
lunches yeah and the lunches were
you know the complete
antithesis of what the other kids
brought so
in the book i write about a friend of
mine
uh
ricky who
every day
this guy can't still be alive
he every day he had a peanut butter
no he had a fluffer nut dirt
fluffernutter sandwich there wasn't even
peanut butter on it it's just fluffernut
so how white can you get yes i want any
pigmentation no
i no
the only thing
more white is like
maybe why martha stewart
maybe
yeah
maybe maybe
and i would bring
a bag but not like a like a little bag
like a little lunch bag like a grocery
bag you know like a plate paper bag
before everybody went to plastic so you
had a grocery bag and i filled it with
excuse me it would be a sandwich of you
know like a half a loaf of italian bread
with
with
eggplant parmigiana whether it be veal
cutlets or
uh
frittata of sorts
um amaze like wow amazing food yeah and
then or
if i had american food i'd have
three peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
like i ate like no really no i like
really ravenous
no like 10 people i eat
and and
i would trade with ricky because he had
the fluff another
that i wasn't allowed to have it was the
contraband that you speak of yeah and i
was so excited i felt so guilty when i
went home
you have such a wonderful voice such a
refined way of speaking that it's so fun
to hear you say fluff or nothing
that's such a great stanley tucci word
because it's because i live in england
yeah oh i wonder are you absorbing you
must be some of the the cadence yeah
yeah yeah of course yeah my kids too the
older ones like madonna um yeah like
madonna yes but but hopefully not yeah
equally talented and sexual
yes yes yes all of us yeah we're all
just we're all like that yeah
but you're all this this one wait no we
all talk like guy richie i really don't
know it's like what's for dinner it's
like yeah what's tonight on me we saw
the duck in there right oh they kept
driving like said hey mike
i'll tell you something and i was like
oh my god i can't believe you're
actually talking it's picky like that he
goes gov take something off women no
logic
i mean really how logic
yeah well
oh i can't that's amazing oh that will
hold up in port and i was like
really
i think i said my wife's very logical
wow you're [ __ ] lucky she's probably
not a woman
yeah he's probably not a [ __ ] woman
no i've been one of those benders right
yeah she might be like a [ __ ] man and
you're like oh my god what's happening
however he he did know where he was
going and that was good
that's what you need but i love those
god you're good at it uh obviously
you're a great actress
no talk to my sister-in-law she goes
stanley oh that's really bad oh really
oh no oh emily oh yeah she goes stanley
oh really and my wife goes stanley no oh
no well you have you because emily is a
genius
yes and a genius and i fancy myself like
you know pretty um sensitive to british
actors doing american accents and like
hearing see their tells the word ben
b-e-e-n there's always one for me or
dean always always right yeah they
always make that mistake but emily is
flawless
emily carey mulligan there's some that
are just like
it's too much i know like you think
how do you do that i can't well you know
but you've done accents and things you
have you have a coach you have a coach
that you rely on
um besides yeah there there's a there's
a couple of there's a couple of people
that uh that i use
um
yeah yeah i don't always
i like to sort of do it in advance and
get it all done yeah do you know what i
mean and then have it so it's just there
right right right because i find if the
person's on the set oh god that'd be you
know what i mean totally sometimes i'm
like oh shut up it's too late for that
it's too late yeah i don't have it now
it's over yes although it's funny the
last time i was in london i was doing
this netflix series uh this this crime
series about a yakuza and it was an all
british cast all british and japanese
cast i was the only american actor whoa
and it was really fun um but they said
but i played a guy from pittsburgh i'd
be the son of this the spoiled son of
this mob boss in pittsburgh and um i i
told them i said you know i've been
working a little bit on a pittsburgh
accent i'm trying to remember it's an
interesting accent the yinzer they call
it yeah and there was like i just
remember phone there was a lot of like
this guy over there he's gonna use yeah
yeah i got to give him a call on the
phone there was a phone
i can't do that but
it's it's no that's it it's baby talk
ours it is
yeah
yeah i got to give that guy a call on
the phone
yes and um i kind of pitched it to them
and
they said no that's that sounds right
that's good and i and i was really
confident about their reaction you know
because they were so positive and then i
realized wait a minute they're all
they're english they don't
they can't hear pittsburgh i could've
done anything they don't know they don't
know yeah but i do also there's no need
for it
none no no one's watching it on the bbc
is gonna know
oh that's like a real pittsburgh oh no
pittsburgh
[Music]
a friend of mine has as well which is
like
accent that's offensive probably to say
accent tourette's but when i hear
accents i can't help
i start doing them back to people um of
course
it's caused some issues but shooting
there is like the the the amount of
different from one
oh it's a stat i love it it's astounding
yeah i mean i mean just every time you
get in a taxi every time you walk into
the shop
everybody on set
you're just like you cannot believe
the diversity person yes i know it's
it's staggering and this is really quite
a small country yeah in comparison to
america yeah
it's really it's really really and they
can all hear it right away they hear it
and they know yeah i know he's from they
go well he's from russia
it's like
[Music]
you've traveled so much in italy now for
the show which is so great i want to
talk about uh searching for italy
did you start picking up
those the variations in the italian
accent
yes that's a very interesting thing and
i've always been fascinated by that
because
my family's from calabria okay and um so
excuse me and i lived in florence for a
year
so
if you
if you when i learned italian i learned
what would be proper italian
in florence florentines consider
themselves
uh proper
italian speakers huh however
they do have a they have they don't have
a dialect
they have an accent
okay so the accent is
uh
they leave off their hard c's
so if you were to say
that the example always is
uh una cosa
de casa
so a thing of the house okay something
of the house
right but in
florentine dialect or
accent you'd say una wholesale your
house huh so they leave
yeah they leave off the cut they
they'd say
as opposed to cafe and that comes from
by all accounts
the spanish influence
so the word matita which means
pencil they'll say matita so they say it
with the like
which is not it's like there is no such
t th is not a sound in italian it's
spanish oh interesting yeah so then if
you go to calabria and i was very
excited to come home after i spoke after
i learned italian in florence i was very
excited to come home were you there for
midsummer night was that midsummer
night's dream no i was there i lived in
florence for a year
oh wow so i was like 12. right so then i
ended up speaking fluently oh cool and
then i come back i try to speak to my my
grandparents
my my um
my mother's parents and i started to
talk to them and i couldn't understand a
word my grandfather said it was that
because what he spoke was like a
different language wow
it wasn't just like an accent so then
you have all those different accents and
dialects
that are throughout the thing so as i'm
shooting the show
i have to have somebody because i don't
really speak fluently fluently
but
nonetheless i need to have somebody
there for that but i also need to have
somebody if i'm in lumber d
and they're speaking they're speaking in
an accent that they're speaking so
quickly and they're speaking they're
changing words and sounds and everything
so i i need somebody there to translate
for me oh wow how if i go to sicily yeah
it's totally different if i go to
uh i'm going to be going to piemonte
i'll be going to different places the
veneto totally different
where are you most comfortable stanley
where's your accent where can you kind
of uh finish i suppose i i suppose
ultimately in in florence because that's
where i learned yeah yeah you know but
if you go to calabria you go to puglia
or something you're like what what's
that guy say is that a frustrating
process i mean i i just
it must be i mean it was especially yeah
it's exhausting
yeah i mean listen you're interviewing
me now right it's tiring i'm i'm oh i'm
exhausted and i'm boring yes but no but
i'm no but you're interviewing someone
and you know you're on camera and you're
eating and you're this and you're
doing it in both languages you're trying
to figure out a way to make it work for
the person that you're talking to but
also for the audience it's a whole new
experience for me and
i have to say
by the end of the day i'm a thousand
times more tired than i've ever been on
a movie i bet well i just the mental the
bandwidth that you must need oh my god
yeah i bet then you're like eating oh is
that good and then you're like have some
more wine
you know oh man okay you left that part
out yeah yeah well it must be god but it
must also on a very like superficial
love it must be so enjoyable it must be
i mean you're that to me is what you're
doing on that show is a fan it's a
fantasy job i'm sure of a lot of people
is that you get to
you know you get to experience this food
and the culture and you seem like such a
naturally curious person so it it seems
it just seems like such a joy to do i
imagine it is a joke it is a joy i mean
now that i think we've figured out how
to do it yeah because you know it's a
learning curve to figure out
you know how many
how many how many cameras do we really
need how many this do you need
should we get this shot should we do
this do we need this do we need an
interpreter do we need blah blah blah um
and then but now i think we figured it
out we have a wonderful director now for
the for some of the new series and i'm
very excited about him it's exciting and
it's interesting for me because it's
what i'm interested yeah yeah if it were
just like how does that jet fly you know
you feel like
whatever i don't care yeah you know um i
want to know i want to know the genesis
of these things yeah i want to know that
i want to know the history
behind
the aubergine or the eggplant i want to
know and i want to know that
when did the arabs bring it there when
did the blah blah and then how do you
make that thing but really how do you
make that thing
and i want to get into the minutia and i
think that also
that's what makes it interesting is that
if you're too general i'm not saying
we're you know
dissecting every obviously it's a
43-minute show i mean you can only do so
much you're trying to tell a lot of
stories but you want to get as deep as
you can given that format you want to
get it into it as deeply as you can
that's what it strikes me yeah that you
do and and it comes from a place of
genuine that what you said a real
curiosity of wanting to know the minutia
because that's also the stuff that helps
um it stick i mean knowing even the
history
you can then make uh connections that
will help uh
a person to meet somebody like me
memorize it just keep it in there yeah i
think so and people always think that
you know
that peop that things need to be and
we'd see this in movies and we've both
made movies where they go like this is
everybody's gonna love this movie
and there's you know and it's a complete
generalization and whatever genre it is
yeah and you're just like and everybody
goes
i hate that [ __ ] you know it's like it
doesn't what is that yeah what is that
it's the specificity
that
that sometimes
makes things really universal
and we can't ever be afraid of that when
you're
writing a movie or directing a movie or
doing a show or whatever it is or
writing whatever it is be specific the
more specific you are
the more universal it will end up being
maybe not in the short term but in the
long term well i think your first two
directing efforts are a perfect
testament to that um they just felt like
big night and the imposters felt like
they were born of your experiences
certainly as an actor my god you said
that about the imposters you're very
kind well i love that it's a movie about
actors and um you know and it's very
it's
it is specific it is very
yes in a very broad way
but but also the examination of it it's
fun too i mean it's a it's uh certainly
very funny and i love oliver platt i
just love that whole group of actors
that you had cultivated this kind of
troop you know like hope davis and um
yeah oliver is so great but uh oliver
yeah yeah incredible actor alfred molina
oh tony uh yeah billy connolly tony
shalhoub oh man isabella
matt mcgrath yes just i was so lucky
allison janney i was so lucky
you know these were my friends yeah yeah
and i was so and still am lucky to have
them as friends but they're just
extraordinarily talented people we we
have a um a question on this show and
i'd like you to pass this on to oliver
uh yeah there's there's a round and we
should get to it i know your time is
limited and i i can't tell you how much
i appreciate you uh taking it no no i'm
so happy to talk to you believe me you
know as you know not all podcasts are
like this that's kind of you uh just
long-winded and rambling uh
yeah that is true um no no well i'm
babbling not at all i love it um
uh we we asked one of the questions is
who was your first uh crush your first
like you know celebrity kind of crush
and last week melanie linski was our
guest uh the great melon and without
missing a beach she said actually i'm
not laughing she said oliver oliver play
it he's my favorite
posters up here on my wall
posters and i said posters of oliver
platt how did you
not to i guess i love oliver and we i
had so much fun with him and i don't
mean this as ninja but yeah how do you
get them how do you get it all yeah
i don't think he knows
and she said uh she said well she grew
up in in new zealand so she said i'll go
to the cinema and i'll get you know the
post the movie poster from the terrible
action and she was just no she would ask
them that's a great accent yes that was
great that's very impressive i love the
way she said yes
yes she's adorable uh she was impressed
that i didn't uh just imitate her the
entire time which is what i decided when
we'd hang out but yeah oliver platt came
with her big so please pass that on to
oliver oh i will of course you know i
talked to him yesterday for the first
time in a long time it was really great
to see him he's a wonderful yeah i oh
gosh i don't know my first crush oh it's
oh well we'll get to it you have time to
think about it it could be it could be
like julie christie oh yeah that makes
sense
um you know what i mean yeah for sure i
mean it was just this is like late 60s
early 70s you were yes so it's a
struggle
as you're seeing as you're watching dr
chibago
well diana rigg
that was tough how do you know right but
uh
uh
julie christie and um
uh geraldine chaplin and man dr chicago
so
you're watching it you think
my god i understand his plight
yes
yeah it takes a real actor
yes how can you not love both of us yes
that's true what it what torturous
torturous life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
there's no delicate way or if there is i
don't know of one to to bring up cancer
so just yeah just say it the word that
you you've unfortunately so accustomed
to
but what you've been talking about i've
been reading about your struggles with
uh having had cancer what what made you
stanley want to talk about it now and
what made i mean you had kept it private
for so long
what was the impetus for um being public
about it well it just it just sort of
made sense if i'm writing a memoir about
food and taste
uh it's so
the treatments so greatly affected
uh
excuse me my taste oh interesting uh
that i
i could not write about it it would be a
lie by omission
so
i had to write about it
uh also it's
incredibly prevalent
uh nowadays
this form of cancer
when the most important part of your
life
is food and everything that surrounds it
meaning
the connection it makes between
uh those you love and those you don't
even know but hopefully will come to
love
you have to write about it
so i was diagnosed with the uh tumor in
at the base of my tongue and then i was
misdiagnosed for two years
uh it was so large when they finally
found it that i couldn't they couldn't
operate so i had to do high-dose uh
radiation
and chemo chemotherapy
that i did uh
sort of increases the efficacy of the
high-dose radiation
luckily it had not metastasized had it
metastasized would be a very different
story
um but i was adamant that i wasn't going
to go through those treatments
because i saw what happened to kate yeah
and she went through those treatments
yeah however her diagnosis
uh type of cancer and prognosis was very
different than mine
so she had been diagnosed with stage
four cancer breast cancer that had
already obviously already metastasized
so it was
former to bones oh god so when she got
the diagnosis it was
too it was already oh god in heaven yeah
so that was four years
of trying to figure it out in the
meantime what during that time we went
all over the world we have we explored
uh treatments in different countries
some of them alternatives some of them
standard of care
uh so i was adamant i wasn't gonna do
standard care because i saw the
devastation yeah
and i had those on the board of a
company that is working with um
alternative protocol treatments but
actually
they are combined with standard of care
or also uses monotherapy
uh and but as a last resort as a last no
no no no now no they're in the test
phase
uh so some of them are being uh the
success rate is amazing oh wow so i'm
i'm really
happy about that and
it's it's really a matter of time
before
we
really get to the point where we don't
have to kill people to save them yeah
yeah um
and that's that's the goal
i'm not saying that chemotherapy or
radiation doesn't work it does work in
certain cases however we do know there
is
a substantial number of people who who
have recurrences so luckily with this
kind of cancer there are certain kinds
of cancer that are
more curable than others
testicular cancer being one of them and
it depends upon the stage the phase the
zones thank you for referencing me so
directly because i'm yeah i'm known for
my testicles
yes yes well yeah no that's why
yeah because i knew i mean eventually
yeah i had my first prostate exam the
other day
how'd that go i was uh rather
unexpectedly enjoyable it was easy it
was much easier than i thought um that's
good but did you
film it uh uh no i had uh
i i just with my mind i took a real
mental note it's something i'll never
forget i did yeah i was laughing with
somebody on the podcast about it because
i i i
you know something that you think about
you the the glove going on and all of
those images are
yeah i knew yes it was coming but it was
the afterwards it was the post the glove
coming off
that the snapping the snapping and the
dismissively
disgustedly tossing it in the
trash i just felt kind of used um yeah
but it was easy it was so much easier
than i how how old do you i'm 43. it's
42. so it was about that time really is
that does that seem too young to get it
no no i think it's good that you go yeah
no you just look like you're 25. like
you don't change i met you once yes at
an hbo party yes if i'm not mistaken
many many years ago yes and almost 20
years ago yeah and i think that you look
exactly the same which is like freaks oh
well it's good lighting um yeah we uh i
think we almost we
i was fired from a job that you did uh a
voice over the tale of despero
do you remember doing you were fired i
was playing desperate i was playing and
i remember gary ross the director said
um yeah gary gary was great and was a
thrill to be around but i remember they
were shooting it they were they were
booming it remember that they were
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was doing it
in a very crazy way yeah well but in
person so i got to do a day with dustin
and like these christopher the actors
and i i almost got to work with you
because of course you oh my god but but
they said as they were this is the
excuse they gave as they were animating
it they said um because he didn't want
me to force my voice up at all i said do
i you know he's a 12 year old mouse you
want me to kind of like gary said no
just do yeah and he said no just do he
wanted it natural and
and so they said as they were animated
my voice was that's the excuse they gave
um they didn't work with my deep voice
but um
i was bummed they made a mistake no no
no
great matthew broderick um but i was i
was bummed to not get to work with you
uh
yes and you were always i remember
meeting you and you being so kind and um
yeah so i'm glad well i was was and
still am a big fan of this oh god man
that means that's the truth this is true
it means a lot yeah of course
likewise obviously um thanks
are you yeah sorry what is it what tell
me
now i'm flattered i'm tongue-tied with
flattery please
um we're back to cancer um yeah sorry i
went on about it
yeah so but now but yeah it was a
struggle i had a feeding tube and i
couldn't eat god
it was really horrible and i it this
destroys your mouth you lose your saliva
oh i still don't have all my saliva back
after three years no kidding how did
they remove it then stanley
radiation purely that wow my god yeah
it shrinks it oh my gosh yeah but the
effects the devastating effects on the
body oh my three
i lost 30 pounds and it was like it was
bad
for how long
how long was the worst was there was the
crippling part of it
oh
a year or more or more
even more
i mean i'm still not
after three years i'm still
i still have to sort of go oh i think i
could eat that oh my god um i think i
could swallow that or yeah well but but
because it hadn't metastasized was there
a part of you that thought well i'll
just i mean or could you have just lived
with it i mean was there a version oh no
no no i would have died oh god no it
would it would have metastasis oh god
and it would have completely taken it
would have completely blocked mine oh
yeah yeah esophagus god
now what are the steps that you go
through i mean obviously you dealt with
that you said for years with kate did it
make you in a way feel closer to her and
her struggle were you thinking about her
of course i was thinking about her all
the time and how brave she was yeah um
how strong she was because it was yeah i
knew that i had a very good
very good chance of surprise okay
and
uh
there was no question that i was going
to survive but that there is always the
question of will it return
all i can say to
anybody who's listening to this if you
feel something unusual for an extended
period of time
in your throat or wherever
just don't be afraid to go get a scan
because it will
in the end it will it could save your
life and that's what it was it was as
simple as i i feel a weird thing
oh no i was in terrible pain few years
god i lived on ibuprofen for two years
so so and
and so you were you so you weren't
getting it checked out i went to doctors
i had scans i had i went to
acupuncturists i did every i did
everything and nobody it wasn't died i
have a very good friend of mine who's a
neurosurgeon who suggested was something
suggested it was something called um
uh
there's something called tribe
trigeminal neuralgia i think or um
nervous intermediate neuralgia uh which
is uh
yeah anyway yeah he was like take this
drug maybe it'll go away and i was like
that didn't work oh my god so these were
great i went all over all of us
everything i mentioned the best doctors
yeah oh my god yeah well a similar thing
happened to my mom they thought it was
fibroids she had one in her an ovarian
cyst um and and uh and it turned out to
be a huge tumor like a grapefruit size
tumor behind it oh my god she's a little
person so it started to show i mean
there were physical um yeah it started
starting to show and and uh they found
that it was fortunately hadn't spread
and um
it was localized but but god how what a
scary time and same thing having to take
that i remember but it was it was it was
cancerous or yeah yeah
no it was it was cancerous it just
hadn't spread oh my the lymph node test
as you well know is the scariest test
because yeah
that's the scary thing yeah and
mine it did not hers didn't go to the
lymph nodes yeah yeah thank god nor did
mine because if it does that
that's harder but
eventually what happens is your
so my lymph
had to be
you know
you have to
deal with it and
so i still have all of this
very hard
firm
uh
sammy's feeling his neck
wow yeah it's not kind of it's like
calcified almost
yeah it's calcified wow it's basically
like these are like
rocks yeah now now what does that do to
you are you first of all you look great
i should have led with that you look
very kind well you do you look like
healthy and
yeah i feel i feel great yeah i feel
great but it's it's it's hard wow it's
hard like this is literally hard hard
and to eat certain things still and you
know oh really and what does it do to
your ability to perform i mean certainly
i'm sure you're just more you're just
more cautious and more aware yeah
wow
and you just want to eat right
you know
do the work you have to do and then get
the proper amount exercise and get the
proper amount of rest well that's what
struck me about a lot of the recipes in
this and and certainly what you do on
the show exploring food in italy there's
um i was just in bulgaria and and i
a place i never would have thought to go
i i loved it sophia
but the food oh wow i loved it i thought
it was the people the really magical
place i thought but the food was so
fresh you know so like there's something
so really simple about it but like such
fresh
uh fresh ingredients and i think they're
very influenced by it they love italian
curcumin
oh that's why i know i was surprised i
know sophia i didn't know that yeah i
would never thought thought
no no but uh that's so cool they're not
playing i would have thought maybe
croatian or yugoslavian or something but
yeah i know whatever that is yeah no i
know surprise but but the freshness of
it the simplicity of it um has that how
much has this experience then changed uh
your cooking your approach to food
oh a great deal yeah yeah i bet a great
deal it it
i always cooked very simply but now it's
even even more so and really
understanding the genesis of that
simplicity makes a big big difference i
mean the other night i made
uh
just spaghetti with bone glaze
and
but then i had bought some botarga which
is the dried fish
red oh yeah rick gray miller
uh and it's it's dried and salted
and then you
just shave it you know
i'll wrap it over
wow
amazing so good it's like four
ingredients oh wow delicious do you do a
big uh christmas eve dinner the seven
course sicilian
fish yeah i do i i used to i do it a bit
now yeah because i really like it i
think it's a really nice antidote to
the
very heavy
christmas yeah the ham
roast yes
definitely in england
yeah uh oh god stanley how i would love
to i'm inviting myself and you you
should come here to massachusetts well
you come i would love it um they're
telling us we gotta wrap up and i'm just
gonna do that
yes because i have to go say goodnight
to my kids oh god okay
jesus here's a quick like a quick uh
two-minute lightning round okay if you
could i'm not gonna ask you about emojis
do you use emojis you don't use emojis
sure yeah your most common vomit if you
had to use one
oh god i don't know yeah um the
martini glass perfect uh if you could be
a professional athlete what sport would
you play
football yeah meaning not not american
soccer
okay um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life your go-to
desert island snack food your stone
peanut butter peanut butter
okay uh your favorite a movie that you
were really excited to share with your
kids that that was influential to you
oh oh uh uh chitty chitty bang bang okay
uh
uh your go to karaoke song i know emily
and john are great carry oh my god um
uh uh our love is here to stay i would
love to hear that um what is your no you
wouldn't not by me i am i disagree uh if
you had to get a tattoo uh what would
you get
uh
what would i get yeah um
a circle
or an egg
okay there's an egg and egg
significance to your cooking
yeah it's just yeah
yeah because it's yeah because it's the
beginning of it you know rockwell's
tattoo you know the the rooster
sam with the rooster no no i'm gonna
tell you no sam's coming up with sam's
coming over this weekend get out of here
no he's been over here like every week
oh that's right he's shooting here oh
that's right he's been shooting with his
beard yeah we're best friends he's my
closest friend i didn't know oh yeah sam
is yes
okay oh my god i'm going to text i'm
going to text him all right i'm going to
try to take his shirt off yeah have him
tell you the rooster story he'll you
know he'll go i just liked it i was 18.
he'll get a little sheepish about it and
the next time i see you i'll tell you
the real story um yeah what is your
favorite fruit
uh blueberries yes some great ones here
uh uh celebrity crush we had mentioned
earlier if you've had time to think
about it you mentioned julie christie
julie christie geraldine chaplin yes uh
uh
oh god um that's perfect um yeah you
have you have a favorite muppet
stanley of the muppets
oh well how could i mean i loved kermit
yes you can't go wrong uh go to pizza
topping
oh no no no nothing nothing really just
tomatoes
i mean you're disgusted by the question
no no yeah
maybe maybe a little
mushrooms maybe okay yeah the beetles
are the rolling stones
oh the beatles and if you could hear a
song right now you haven't heard such
and such in a while what beto song would
you like to hear
oh what beatles song yeah
oh god there are millions of them but
probably um uh
let it be ah yeah well i'm gonna let
that be awesome yes perfect and thank
you so much for taking the time today oh
my god justin this has been so much fun
i'm so sorry for being so verbose not at
all thank you i'm fascinated i love this
book we're going to talk all about it um
when you're not on here and give
rockwell give him a squeeze for me
we're going to send you a little video
okay all right
awesome all right okay all right and
then much love and
send everyone my best all right i will
of course thanks okay ciao ciao thank
you
bye bye bye bye bye
[Music]
so so
that just happened yeah can't do it
soothing
yes very comforting
and um
and and there's something kind of like
seductive about it whoa
didn't think you'd use that word i got
touched yeah you sure did you
you sure did yeah he touched me in my in
my
special place yes after my heart after
the interview i asked i went and you
were like blushing you were like it was
he's the best oh man you know what he's
great you know i've often heard from
women from it's and so then
that he is uh they find him very sexy
so i get that oh see i hadn't gotten
until i interacted with him he's just so
charming for one thing he was a former
model
so he's very handsome
he is he's also
um a very charming person he's a great
personality to just not consider a bald
man male oh i'm sure i'm sure that's a
factor yeah do you know how many women
find vin diesel attractive oh that's
true that's true and telly symbolizes
there's been a lot of bald sex symbols
patrick stewart oh my god patrick
stewart yes
did i just
oh yeah oh god yeah he what a like
soothing voice cool guy i get why you
were smitten and also like there's a
little bit of
like goals you
with him you know like in terms of the
cooking
cooking cooking and and and marrying a
blunt marrying a blunt of course like
what a charmander assembly you know i i
don't know if i mentioned i think i told
him there aren't more blunts are there
just the two they're just the two yeah i
think i think so um they got taken by
two two greats krasinski and tuch yes
two two the great are great specimens
our genders
really great representatives um and i
hate to be blunt but um
i like them both so much
oh boy felicity and emily uh hopefully
they're listening i doubt they are
these they might be they are because her
husband do you think if i were married
to somebody i don't know if i'd want to
hear all of their podcasts
um anyway the blondes are great the
blunts
also he is um like appropriately
self-deprecating in a way that is yes
charming and
um believable you know like he kept
saying that he was verbose which i i
happen to think he wasn't being verbose
but he mentioned it a few times he's
like i'm being verbose yeah um and i'm
being boring you know he'd say things
like that i'm boring and it's a sign
that i believe that he believed that i
don't think he was being falsely modest
because you know i don't like false
monsters no no
but i uh i i liked
that amount of uh self deprecation yeah
it says it says that he's uh i think
that's what you aspire to too i do i do
i i don't wanna i tend to go overboard
with that and and i know what he means
like i feel him on
especially when you're the guest of a
thing like this
you find that um i mean it's the whole
point is to hear from him obviously of
course but i'm talking about your own
life
it's a little um it's indulgent it's
inherently indulgent right so he kept
recognizing that indulgence which is
cool and not a lot of our i'm not
some of our guests don't always have
that kind of gauge
he's tucci yeah he's he's got a he's um
i think he exists on a somewhat
elevated level is that fair to say it is
very fair yeah he's um he's just a tooch
above everyone
um he's so like uh what's the word um
like erudite you know i know but without
being pretentious that's a rare
conversation he knows so much but he and
he's so curious and i and i was struck
by that too every time yes
you would offer something whether it was
uh you know
some like a recipe you knew about or the
fact that um you were talking about
bulgaria having fresh food he really lit
up with
curiosity did oh tell me yeah oh really
yeah i didn't know that and he loved
getting the information that's why he
loved
what they were saying that's why his
show is so great i mean i think that's
the mark of a really great host he seems
genuinely curious and he's like he's got
this insatiable interest in in finding
out things in the world and exploring we
should say what his show is oh the name
of it right yeah we'll go ahead
searching for italy yes yeah which i've
recently started watching have you seen
it yet i have oh it's so good i've only
saw one episode me too you don't both
have only seen one episode of searching
for them but for like months doesn't it
immediately make you want to go there
well yes yeah oh my god i mean i've
always wanted to go there but uh and
i've never been but i you know both have
not have been to italy it's crazy that
you haven't been i know with all your
traveling i know a couple times i can't
believe you haven't been no i know i i
might that's the thing and and now
because there's so much build up about
it like i want to save it for the i want
to go for the proper amount of time save
it for later
um
but that show also makes me think of
well i think you said this to him that
our parents
i think every single time i saw them
over the course of
like a two-month period they would ask
me if i had seen yes searching for italy
it was like they're they were obsessed
with it yeah they get in really into
shows and but they're obsessed with him
too and they always have for a long time
well like we said i mean like they were
also really into big night when it came
out i remember
when those because they were uh in their
mid 90s i don't i forgot however old
they were they were you know 50 in their
50s 60s and the two sets of parents our
parents and our family friends would
just get like light up when they talk
about big night it was it was a thing
that they shared that they like would
break
every single year for
like you said a decade at least also our
parents both
really value
intelligence
and
um
you know knowledge
and
after hearing from him i had never heard
such a long um conversation with stanley
tucci i
understand that even more why they why
they're so enamored by him because he is
so intelligent
and he's italian and he's a cook and i
know it's like of course they love him
well i think that's the that's what i
really enjoy about his type of curiosity
is that he um
he's curious about things in in life
that i also enjoy and i guess food is a
big one food and travel and and blunts
and
blunts and acting yeah accents that was
fun he's amazing at accents i know
i know and he was self self deprecating
about that sure was yeah classic touch
um but i i think that's the thing about
cooking too is that
there is um it feeds a curious person it
feeds somebody who likes learning about
um i mean i think any i guess any
discipline does but you know something
it's so connected uniquely connective
yeah and creative
about it um what do you say conviviality
he said so um i've never used that i
haven't either i've heard of it
convivially yeah but he said it so
effortlessly but yeah that really is the
word you know
yes it is yeah it's something that
really brings people together and brings
joy
i loved how he said fluffernutter
oh yeah such an
impressive classy way
fluff or not but he admitted to liking
them yeah and to i never got into fluff
for nutter
um i've had fluffernutter wait
fluffernutter means peanut butter and
the fluff right yeah
but you love fluff no the opposite i
like the peanut butter part of it the
fluff always seems no i'm not saying
that the combination to me i know you
know both have to not really be into the
combination of marshmallow fluff and
peanut butter i was never into that
combination they it kind of like offset
each other i love them both separately i
don't love the um fluff separately you
don't not really you've never had fluff
on a sundae ugh really it's gross how
you did that with your fluff on sunday
you feel like a big dollop of it a big
yeah i'm not into fluff
really marshmallows i'm not that into
marshmallows
really i don't hate them
but i'm not that into marshmallows not
that i like them but freeze on cocoa if
you're hot cocoa hot chocolate uh yeah i
guess but it's like all right i'll take
it but i don't need it to enjoy the hot
chocolate like in a s'more man i'm sorry
in a s'more of the three ingredients the
marshmallow is by far my least favorite
really yeah how does it how do you rank
them chocolate
i guess chocolate graham cracker
marshmallow wow
that's surprising i'm surprised that you
don't because i i find them really
great in hot cocoa cool
i find them kind of bland and neither
here nor there wow okay well to each his
own yeah more more for me more fluff for
me it's fun to disagree with you about
things like that yeah i know it's rare
yeah which makes it nice i think but you
know but you know i guess maybe because
we didn't have a lot of marshmallows
growing up we didn't fluff certainly we
never got fluff only in school like i
did the same thing i do
band yes and it was more like of course
yeah same with uh fruit roll-ups uh-huh
it was so exciting when someone traded
your fruit roll-ups for the best fruit
by the foot yes god i love fruit
roll-ups
always groceries yeah but you know
what's gross about fruit roll-ups i know
this is way off topic but you know they
used to know she's gonna love this
they'd have the shapes obviously like
that where you punch out the difference
that came a little bit later oh really
that was my memory of fruit rolls no no
no i know what you're saying yeah and it
always grosses me out when kids with
their grubby kid hang out i know you're
going to say they would like poke them
out
and then they would like wrap it around
their fingers you know who did that a
lot i know some people who do that a lot
we shouldn't say who did it a lot well
they won't know the first name
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
um that used to i know i knew that and
they'd suck on it i know yeah i did not
like that can you imagine that that was
like the um seedlings of my germaphobia
yes but i think well now it's like
somewhat
it's more understandable i would think i
mean happy half course people are gonna
the whole population is going to think
differently about stuff like that after
you know what we've been through as a
society sure after cobit um
you brought up your prostate exam again
again yeah and yeah unexpectedly
enjoyable i did yeah
unexpectedly enjoyable i believe those
are the words you chose yes i said that
i think so unless i misheard it
i said you're
playful and flirty with them
you're being like friend flirty
you know what if i'm just like buy two
chews
what if i'm like i'm
i'm only bisexual when it comes to
tucci impossible no you got really
excited that he's friends with sam
you're like yeah you're like i like
his best friend i wanted to connect yeah
because sam ended up going over there
that weekend oh really yeah and they
hung out i was so jealous i couldn't be
there because they were in london wait
what i said i can't believe i said i
must have been i'm i hope i didn't i
said well what's wrong with that what if
i didn't find it if your doctor is
listening i hope he knows that you're no
kidding
i'm sure he knows because he was there
he knows it wasn't you had a real um
made me laugh
i was i was happy that it was over i was
like oh i i'm glad i did it because i
know that of course of course but it's
funny that you keep talking about it
well i also want i think it's another
way to connect because he's an older man
you know so i wanted to like let him
know that i was in the club and he's
dealt with yes like scary healthy yeah
yeah yeah um oh so you're a hero
yeah um you had real lightning around
panic when he said he had to go and he
had to put his kids to bed you were like
you're like oh god i know oh god i think
well well because i don't want to
disappoint him i don't want to like you
don't disappoint disappoint a blunt i
wouldn't say just disappoint a blunt i
just know i don't i don't want to
disappoint any of them in that blind
putting his kids to bed oh my god you're
like oh okay and then you're like uh
what's your favorite emoji you probably
don't use emojis
i did
and he's like oh i don't know
oh man that was terrible yeah and i was
like yeah who cares this show is dumb
um but also like
after what he'd been through after also
like giving me so much of his time
you know of course
and the whatever i get it i get why you
panic yeah uh let's read a letter oh wow
yeah is that abrupt a blood a blunt
um
yeah no i i just could go on about tucci
i know but no one wants to hear us talk
too much about this okay
hank daniels this is from hank daniels
what a name hank daniels who do you
think what do you think right away go
hank daniels yeah i think of uh hank
hill yeah i think of um the guy who used
to sing the monday night football or oh
yeah hank williams hank williams are you
ready for some hank from breaking bad uh
and daniel's jack daniels hank daniels
what what a like solid name the devil
went down to georgia he was looking for
a you know
soul to steal
did that guy um did he just talk all of
his songs the devil went down to georgia
he was looking for a soul to steal i
don't know if i've ever heard any of his
other songs and ding dong i don't like
that song
let's read the letter is that going
gonna be in your head now yes do you
know any other lyrics from him no
okay it's a huge hit well i know um
hank daniels subject great idea for some
great guys oh i hope he's talking about
us
he might not be though i don't want to
assume
hi michelle chris and justin oh
i've really been enjoying your podcast
lately oh thanks hank
thanks hank that's a fun one to say he's
a that's a fun person thanks
thank you justin and i are the same age
and i've always felt a kinship with him
from his movies and weirdly felt like we
seemed to grow up together ah
thanks
hearing the story of him working up the
courage to tell that girl how he felt
about her and your mom's old pontiac
really did make me wonder if we were
actually the same person
did we say that it was a pontiac yeah
bonneville yeah
how else would he know that
um brought me back to the many times i
had done the exact same thing in the
exact same car
my favorite movie of yours is a case of
you wow
all right i'm glad you're sitting down
for this wow back to hank find a nickel
for every time i've heard that how much
would you have a nickel yeah well get
ready for this he says back to hank what
a masterpiece
wow well done gentlemen wow thank you
thank you yeah thanks thanks um thank
you and of course i love accepted in
dodgeball speaking of dog that was hank
not me i was insane
um speaking of dodgeball this brings me
to my idea after i listened to your
steven rude episode i was left
absolutely gutted and haunted by the
story of his father bonding with his
horse during wartime and having to send
it off to the glue factory after the war
was over yeah that was a crazy story um
he said please make that movie
that's actually not a bad idea
i don't really think we'd be good at
making that movie but i do think that
movie should be made yeah that's a
really cool idea yes that's like an epic
that's a cool idea
um i know somebody who might okay
um ice back to hank i smell an oscar
uh unless that's the horse's name oscar
i'm serious that would really be one for
the aegis what do you mean i'm serious
so maybe he was joking about smelling an
oscar yeah we're not gonna make an
obstacle anymore no but
that idea could be oscar sure winnable
sure um i'm a professional video editor
and have dabbled in writing over the
years as well so i'm happy to help get
the ball rolling any which way i can
okay great
we might reach out to you hank um
now we have his email
anyways back to hank anyways would you
rather have to ride a large dog as your
only form of transportation or have the
ability to fly and be your own source of
transportation but you would never be
able to touch the ground or your bed or
anything you weren't physically holding
onto as you'd always be floating or
hovering
well could i sleep while hovering
i'm sure
uh
i guess i would do that
uh i want to sit on a big dog i feel bad
for one thing i'd feel really bad for
the dog well i had to take me everywhere
well not if it was like falcore you know
like a big never-ending story dog is
that the name of the dog falcore i think
so but then i would be oh no think about
dragon that's a lucky oh you're right
you're not a dog it looks like a dog but
think about
just the mechanics oh look
think about the mechanics of having to
take a dog everywhere when the rest of
the population is taking cars and bikes
and training that is true for one thing
that's a problem
i'd feel bad for the dog even if he was
used to it
and um i wouldn't be able to go overseas
i wouldn't be able to go anywhere that
wasn't in the continental united states
uh you could get sick i would be lying
in a bed i think but maybe not if if i
could hover and sleep
i would do that human contact you can
touch things as you're hovering you'd
have to like touch everyone while you're
hungry you get used to it i would hover
like half an inch above the ground think
about it
think about it i'd get used to it i know
no i know would your would the other
person get used to it
they'd have to oh well okay
uh and also the large dog this might be
a loophole about the large dog but
couldn't you
first of all i'm picturing a dog that is
like clifford i'm picturing the big red
dog clifford do you know how ridiculous
you'd look
driving clifford oh you around town
you'd move you'd go places quickly you'd
i mean to get you'd be able to do a
cross-country trip with clifford in like
probably
a couple couple youth hours slippard is
that kind of stamina well i'm assuming
yeah a dog a dog that size you're like a
woolly mammoth you're imagining like a a
extraterrestrial type of dog that had
super powers no i'm not a dog because a
dog
even a big dog obviously like dogs don't
exist now i know like a pretty historic
i know but they don't they would get
exhausted taking you from here to there
here to like cleveland ohio you think a
dog has the stamina to take you oh maybe
not come on because i know those great
danes they get tired pretty quickly of
course big dogs they can take you to the
supermarket so how about this would i be
able to sit on the dog and then sit on
another and have that dog be in another
form of transportation like a plane or
something no well then i guess i would
probably fly to
god i just have to get used to certain
things hover yeah you're right i'd hover
a couple in like an inch off the ground
but you barely to the point where you'd
get so good at hovering that people
wouldn't know you're hovering yeah it'd
be like a hovercraft without that it
would be like an optical illusion
oh yeah you'd have to get certain kind
of shoes that made it look like you were
standing on the pavement that's true i
guess i could still act that in that
because this i can walk get over the
acting thing by the way this
hypothetical is so extreme that's true
that you would like you'd have to be
comfortable doing a different career and
then think about the pr the pros of it
the plus side you could do the podcast
you just float above the chair and
talking to the microphone that's true
i'd probably
be but wouldn't you have to exert some
energy to do that to to float i don't
know i don't know is that is that yeah
that's the end of the letter um thanks
for the entertainment and such be well
hank thanks for the entertainment that's
a great letter it's a good hypothetical
hank what a great name too
you don't hear a lot of hanks anymore
hey henry
i think of uh james's dad too hank oh of
course yeah
hank duffy man what a great guy our
friend james had his his dad was so
gregarious and fun to be around that was
that's his dad is the reason i don't
drink wine anymore you told that story
yeah so thank you hank and if you guys
would like to write into the show like
hank did our email address is life is
short at wondery.com and thanks to
stanley tucci another great
old-fashioned name stanley yeah i love
that name you don't both upload the
names
um thanks for listening everybody oh and
go check out stanley's book true um
oh man is it good oh stan is it good and
we'll talk to you next week okay and big
night if you haven't seen it and all of
tucci's ubra
uh we love him we're so grateful to him
and we're grateful
and we're grateful to all of you for
listening
so
thank you and i'll talk to you next week
so will you i hope so
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted by you christian
long it's also produced by megan v
monaco also uh produced katie allen
katie allen senior producer is michelle
miesh lans and the audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
marshall louie for a company name of
wandery
[Music]
is he doing another one of those shows i
think so i think they're going to keep
doing them uh
searching for yeah do you like do you
like that show
oh i love that show it's so good i was
i'm waiting for the uh
are you taping this
[Laughter]
i thought you'd want to be part of the
episode
oh
gosh justin well what do you want to be
part of the episode he's one of your
favorites
yeah but i'm not saying anything that's
uh
at all revelatory yeah you did and you
said at the end you said that's a nice
thing to use how excited you are for the
show
yeah new season
so um uh yeah and i we're live by the
way
what
i'm just
kidding you know i love the fact that
he's a home cook
i made his
pasta with zucchini it's so delicious
have you made that no
ugh
you